و guna هي واحدة من الوجهات الأكثر شهرة في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، حيث أن الطائرات الورقية
[الموسيقى]
والرياح المستمرة ، والأيام المشمسة
والمياه الضحلة حولت الجونة إلى
وجهة عالمية لراكبي الطائرات الورقية ،
استضفنا العديد من
المسابقات
الدولية لمومو ، حيث بدأ الشغف بهذه
الرياضة في  في سن مبكرة
رأيتها ، كان عمري 14 عامًا في
منزلي ، لقد رأيت للتو رجلًا يقطع
، وبعد ذلك كنت أشاهده
وكأنني معجب تمامًا كما لو أنني
سأفعل ذلك منذ هذا اليوم وقعت واحدة ضخمة في
الحب  مع الرياضة ، مومو هو واحد من
العديد من المدربين الذين يعملون في مدرسة ركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية
في الجونة ، وهو
منتجع تم بناؤه خصيصًا على طول الساحل الغربي
للبحر الأحمر ، وهو اليوم يصطحب
مجموعة من راكبي رياضة ركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية إلى أحد
أفضل مواقع التنزه في العالم والتي تسمى
تايلاند  يعد عمر مودريتش ، البالغ من العمر 16 عامًا ، من أشهر
الوجهات لركوب الأمواج في
جميع أنواع طلابه
عندما
تهبط في الهواء عندما تتعلم خدعة جديدة ،
فهذا هو الشعور  لا يمكنك
وصف ذلك حقًا
على الرغم من أن أوما لم يمارس رياضة ركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية إلا
منذ خمس سنوات ، فهو بالفعل
بطل حامل لقب مصر
[موسيقى].
حلمي هو أن تصبح
بطلاً للعالم بالكامل سيأتي إليك
يومًا ما
[موسيقى]
مع سرعة رياح تضرب  بعد 50 كم / ساعة
في موسم الذروة ، هناك فرصة
كبيرة لمومو لاختبار مهاراته لي
، لا يزال هناك الكثير لنتعلمه
بالتأكيد
سأستمر في تعلم كل يوم مسارات جديدة
للشعور الذي ينتابك عندما تكون
هناك طائرة ورقية و  الرياح ليس
لديك محرك ، ليس لديك زيت ، ليس
لديك غاز أو أي شيء يشبه نوعًا من
الحرية أشعر
أنني لن أتوقف حتى آخر يوم
لي كما لو أنني سأستمر في فعل
ذلك لبقية  حياتي
[موسيقى]